okay didn't you also get into a
helicopter accident
yeah um yeah i can't talk much about it
because there's things going on but yeah
i got into
oh really no i can't i can't like make
it i can't make a public aware or who
was involved but yeah i was in
can you tell us what happened yes we
crashed into the water i was a passenger
and recently oh uh 2020 of october
october 2020. so why were you in a
helicopter just for fun
i've
you know it was just a pilot error and
um we
crashed into the water we just got too
close to the water and it we were
hovering near like we weren't high up we
just hovered right on top of it and the
skis caught the water or whatever
skids caught the water and we front
flipped in and luckily the doors were
off because the whole thing filled up
with water immediately now you're saying
luckily the doors were yeah because i
wouldn't have been able to get out
because it filled up with water and i
was stuck in my belts for about 30
seconds i was just i thought i was gonna
die a hundred percent i was like all
right like this is it that's one of my
biggest fears right there it's like that
movie
helicopter yeah like
and so thank god the doors were off we
swam up and out
[Laughter]
my biggest fears is being in water and
helicopter
honestly that's not something i've ever
thought about that would happen but
yeah so wait so he ruined your story um
you're upside down and it fills with
water and you can't undo you i can't get
out of my belts which was the scariest
part how many people are in the
helicopter three of us and it was my
videographer the pilot and i and i was
wait a second did you video is this on
video yeah but we can't like
like i haven't i don't know if i want to
release it or anything it's kind of
scary
you know
for the person in the water you have it
on your phone now no i don't have it on
my phone it's back on like a drive but
he wants you
to know that
but nobody's exclusive no one died we
all made it out but it was just scary
because the belt was stuck and i thought
it's just the way the helicopter belts
work with pressure and no i know because
there is a famous uh crash on the hudson
river in new york it was tourists and
the same thing happened they couldn't
get out of their building
nope
see that i didn't think i would and the
thing about helicopter belts is they
really don't go good with anything other
than a helicopter shouldn't that change
that whereas it's just the way the
pressure isn't like probably yeah it was
crazy but thank god we all got out and
we're all good and i think you were
gonna die oh my god 100 likes let's go
slow down
the thing hits the water yeah it was so
the crash wasn't bad because i've gotten
in car crashes with racing like you just
like you know roll with it you get crap
yeah you get into crashes so i was like
all right just roll with it this is fine
like whatever and i just like i can't
believe this has happened because i've
had two friends pass away in a
helicopter crash in 2019 and then kobe
happened so i was like okay like
this does not work if you had two
friends die in a helicopter why would
you even get it i didn't want to i was
like i don't want to and like everyone
was like you just should do it i was
creating a video that day they're like
this is such good footage like i have
friends who are pilots like kinsey's a
pilot like i knew they're they're
usually safe so i was like okay like
i'll try it out i'll face my fear and i
put up a snapchat that actually said
facing my fears right before i went out
oh my god and then i crashed and i was
like okay what are the odds that that
happens my very first time so but how
long did it take from the time it hit
the water to have the the cockpit fill
up with immediately because the doors
are really tall and you know they were
off so it just completely filled up with
water so did he not sink no we were
sinking and it was only about 40 feet
deep because it was one of those it was
one of those
like lake things that you can jet pack
on and stuff like that so it wasn't
super deep in the water was crystal
clear so i was opening my eyes and i was
able to like look at my belt you know if
this happened to bill burr he would have
played the drums
it was crazy what
flies helicopters right right yeah
yeah it's and plays the drums
yeah well yeah he probably would have
played the drums andrea
and just like i don't know if i should
come on the podcast and mess up the flow
no i don't want to mess up the flow of
this podcast don't worry i'm in the
office
that's an amazing story and i'm so glad
that you're alive thank you the story's
not over yeah that's pretty much no but
i wanna you wanna go through okay is
that a problem yeah no no no so i wanna
because so now it fills up automatically
you're looking at the at the belt it's
going down what did what about the other
people in the i don't know the guy in
the back the doors were on so he had to
come up and through to get out and he
actually got out before me because i
think he just like was calm and like
undid them like i was panicking like i
couldn't get it undone because i was
panicking rightfully so it's like trying
to get your necklace on when you're
panicking you can't do it dude that's
like a way i don't i don't panic when i
put on my necklace
you can't get it on you're like oh this
is so annoying and then you just have to
calm down and do it that's like kind of
it's not like
if it's not like what she said
i cannot relate
let's not all talk at once
if it's that's a really shitty analogy
okay no it's a good story to explain
like exactly how it felt and i'm like to
me it feels like when you're trying to
put on a necklace oh i know and you're
going i'm trying to put on this necklace
and i think if i don't put on this
necklace i'm going to die
if i show up at the restaurant
if i show up at the restaurant without
this brooch on i don't know how i'm
going to survive well i can relate to
that
[Music]